pancarte à la main alice tente de
rallier jargeau une commune située à
seulement cinq kilomètres mais faute de
bus régulier la jeune femme y ce matin
sur réseau pousse un système d'auto stop
organisé et justement voici didier un
automobiliste inscrits sur la plateforme
bonjour à vous digne et fauqué présente
depuis l'été dernier dans le loiret le
système entièrement gratuit propose un
coup de pouce à ceux qui n'ont pas de
voiture pour le chauffeur pas de
rétribution le mot d'ordre est la
solidarité je fais pas taxi en fait je
je je fais ce déplacement parce que moi
j'en ai besoin personnellement et plutôt
que le faire tout seul dans ma voiture
qui a quatre places je préfère en faire
profiter d'autres personnes qui ont pas
les moyens de se déplacer c'est
précisément le cas d'alice en recherche
d'emploi et qui tente par tous les
moyens de réduire ses dépenses
de prêt perso j'ai pas mon véhicule mais
si j'avais mon véhicule c'est sûr que là
par rapport au prix de l'essence c'est
mieux de de privilégier le covoiturage
enfin l'auto stop tout que
de sacrifier un peu un peu d'argent quoi
pour un plein donc c'est vraiment
intéressant financièrement
subventionné par les collectivités et
animé sur le territoire par le pôle
d'équilibré territorial et rural forêt
d'orléans loire sologne le déploiement
du dispositif représente un coût de 25
mille euros un investissement nécessaire
pour répondre à la question de la
mobilité et de l'écologie en milieu
rural ou trois quarts des déplacements
se font en voiture ça répond pas à tous
mais c'est une partie de la réponse déjà
sur les économies qu'on peut faire aussi
bien en so2 que
que financièrement pour les personnes
qui prennent le réseau plus en quelques
mois le système risque de pouce a
enregistré plus de 250 inscrits sur les
49 communes de l'ap être forêt d'orléans
le loir sologne